حادث من جانب همم القياده السياسيه في
باكستان فقط ايضا نتابع معك اذا سمحت فقط
الصور التي
نتبعها الان هي لحظه القبض على مطلق النار
على رئيس الوزراء السابق
يبدو ان همم من اطلق النار يرتدي هذا
القميص الازرق هو اا من اطلق النار عليه
ولا هذا الحديث اسود ويبدو ان وكاله
الانباء الفرنسيه نقلت انه قد تم همم قتله
في الواقع هذه اللحظه تظهر امساك الامساك
به ولكن يبدو انه قتل في وقت لاحقا عليه
همم النيران لا نعرف هويه هذا الشخص حتى
الان همم كما ذكرت هذه الصور انه يتبعها
معكم همم مشاهدينا الكرام مباشره على
الهواء مشاهده همم معكم وان يحاول ايضا ان
يحللها ونعرف همم المزيد من التفاصيل بشان
عمليه الاغتيال هذا كما ذكرنا يعني تم
اطلاق النار على همم عمران خار بعد ما
ترجل من السياره التي همم كان يستقلها همم
للمشاركه في مظاهره من جانب انصارح
يطالبون بانتخابات مبكرا اذا هذا الرجل
الذي تشاهدون الان على الشاشه هو اا من
اطلق النار على عمران خار